hello welcome to my video series where I
explain fire techniques within 5 minutes
if you haven't subscribed to my channel
while you are waiting for please
subscribe so today's topic is ship sick
or chromatin immunoprecipitation
followed by sequencing so this is used
to study DNA protein interaction in
vitro or in vivo so let's say we have
identified a noble transcription factor
and we don't know that what this
transcription factor regulates or what
gene does it transcribe so first
question we should ask that with gene
does it frivolity in order to do that we
have to do some technique and inside the
cell nucleus there is chromatin our
transcription factor binding the
chromatin region and transcribe a
specific gene or it might regulate a lot
of Gina plethora of gene so we don't
know that in order to understand with
genes or which sequences is fine do we
have to do some technique known as chip
sick in this chip sake let's say our
transcription factor is bind to its
desired DNA sequence so we would share
the DNA says that the chromatin would be
fragmented and we would use an antibody
against that transcription factor and
couple that antibody with the sepharose
or a magnetic bit after there that
particular pull-down fraction could be
pulled down using a centrifuge or a
magnetic separation if it is a magnetic
bead now what is left after pulling down
with the beep is the pull down fraction
and definitely we can take out the pull
down fraction with a pipette and after
that this pull down fraction is
processed and loaded onto DNA sequencing
machine and DNA sequencing would give
you a readout in forms of sequences so
here is the brief readout so it would
read all the sequences associated with
that pull down fraction and it would
align those sequences with the known
sequences of the genome and we would get
a signaling peak which suggests that
that particular sequence is present
ample amount in the pulldown sequence
for example here you can see three boxes
three representing three short sequences
which are enriched in this particular
pulldown fraction that in turn tells you
that these transcription factor binds
are enriched in those DNA sequences or
otherwise those are the regulatory
elements where these noble transcription
factor binds now a global approach is
chip-sequencing but if you do I want to
do a local approach you can also do a
chip qPCR where you have the pulldown
fraction from the pulldown fraction you
qPCR for a specific gene of interest now
out of many genes or gene fragments that
are pulled down using the beat if your
gene of interest is there it should be
detected in real time PCR and that is
how you would detect whether the gene of
interest is present in the pulldown
fraction or not that would give you an
idea in turn that whether the
transcription factor binds to that
specific gene of interest or not so if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to share
subscribe and like thank you